wie soll das nur weitergehen fragt ihr
euch vielleicht auch die Politik sitzt
in der Patsche manche Überschriften
sagen alles Koalition in der me Krise
Ampel am Abgrund the most German crisis
ever nicht nur eine Haushaltskrise
sondern es ist eine megakrise das höre
ich auch direkt aus dem
Bundesfinanzministerium das ist wirklich
eine verdammt gefährliche Lage für
Deutschland selbst Finanzminister
Christian Lindner scheint völlig
geschockt über das Urteil und irgendwie
auch ratlos für die Ampel die sowieso ja
schon mit Ach und Krach regiert ist das
eine Zerreisprobe die Ampel ist völlig
plan und kopflos im Grunde genommen
haben wir eine Regierung die nur noch
taumelt nun müssen die sich einigen nur
die Pole gehen ja so weit auseinander
Schuldenbremse aufweichen Rente mit 63
Weg Bürgergeld kürzen
Dienstwagenprivileg abschaffen es gibt
viele Ideen und es gibt Zoff und es gibt
noch eine andere Idee diese
Schuldenbremse wirkt ökonomisch falsch
und deswegen lade ich die gesamte Union
ein hier mit uns in Gespräche
einzutreten dass wir hier zu einer
gemeinsamen und zukunftsgerichteten
Reform der Schuldenbremse kommen die
Grünen bitten die CDU um Gespräche also
die Not ist wirklich groß manche sagen
jetzt auch die Ampel kann es einfach
nicht Punkt sind SPD Grüne und FDP
gemeinsam nicht regierungsfähig
zerbricht vielleicht sogar die Ampel
manche einer in der Republik träumt gar
von Neuwahlen völliger Quatsch wir
schauen hin inside
politics mein Name ist Britta Bucholz
ich bin im ZDF Hauptstadtstudio auch für
Finanzen zuständig und jetzt versuche
ich hier mal ein paar Dinge auseinander
zu Fusseln erstmal wo ist eigentlich
Olaf Scholz erst sagte er tagelang
nichts obwohl der buchungstrick ja vor
allem auf sein konnte geht damals wurde
ja entschieden den Fond nicht nur von
coronahilfen auf klimafond umzuwidmen
sondern das Geld einfach auf das andere
Jahr zu buchen indem die Schuldenbremse
ausgesetzt war auch wenn es über mehrere
Jahre ausgezahlt werden sollte das
schien eine richtig tolle Idee denn so
konnten Projekte finanziert werden um
den in der Verfassung verankerten
Klimaschutz zu realisieren und
gleichzeitig konnte Christian Lindner
einen regulären Haushalt verabschieden
der so tat als hielte er die
Schuldenbremse ein Olaf Scholz könnte
das ja jetzt selbst der erklären macht
er aber nicht das war ganz lustig weil
wir Journalisten warteten einmal auf ein
angekündigtes Statement aber dann kam
das ein Video also mehr so eine Art Rede
an die Nation von Olaf Scholz den
Haushalt für das nächste Jahr werden wir
im Lichte des Urteils genau überarbeiten
zügig aber mit der gebotenen Sorgfalt
sein FZE Robert Habeck hatte dagegen
richtig Gesprächsbedarf erklärte sich
vor vielen Kameras in der Talkshow
Markus Lanz machte er sich dann
regelrecht Lust über seinen Chef
Scholz ich will jetzt nicht den
Bundeskanzler zitieren aber ich kann
mich nicht mehr daran erinnern und dann
kam fast zwei Wochen nach dem
schockurteil eine Regierungserklärung
und Olaf Scholz bricht sein Schweigen
aber er sagt fast nichts wir haben
Vorsorge getroffen damit nicht
automatisch neue finanzielle
Verpflichtung für die kommenden Jahre
eingegangen werden und zwar sol lange
bis wir alle Fragen präzise beantwortet
haben die sich nach dem Urteil stellen
wichtig ist laufende Ausgaben sind davon
nicht betroffen der Staat wird seinen
Aufgaben auch weiterhin gerecht Scholz
will also wieder Führung übernehmen die
ihm so lange abgesprochen wurde aber
auch in seiner Regierungserklärung kam
noch nicht so wirklich viel dafür kam
der Oppositionsführer so richtig in Rage
sie sind ein klemtner der macht ihnen
fehlt jede Vorstellung davon wie dieses
Land sich in den nächsten Jahren
weiterentwickeln soll die einen wollen
nicht sparen und die anderen wollen
nicht ausgeben das ist ja so eine
Quadratur des Kreises die ihren Ursprung
aber schon vor z Jahren genommen
[Musik]
hat die Ampel hat ja einen Geburtsfehler
bei den Koalitionsverhandlungen bekam
die SPD die Zusage Sozialleistung
ausbauen zu dürfen aus hz4 wurde ja das
Bürgergeld das wurde dann erhöht nur um
mal eine Zahl zu nennen die Kosten für
das Bürgergeld ehemals Arbeitslosengeld
2 sind mit rund 24 Milliarden Euro pro
Jahr festgelegt der Arbeitsminister Heil
hat dann noch mal eben rund 3 Milliarden
mehr gebraucht als eigentlich geplant
die Grünen bekamen Investitionen in den
Klimaschutz vor allem aus dem Klima und
transformationsfond finanziert der jetzt
dahin ist also 60 Milliarden Euro allein
dort eingeplant und die FDP die setzte
ihr Leib und magentha durch keine
Steuererhöhung und kein Aufweichen der
Schuldenbremse merkt ihr was wenn ihr
euch das genau ansieht es passt
überhaupt nicht nicht zusammen denn es
gibt zwar Rekord Steuereinnahmen nur die
konnten all diese Projekte ja gar nicht
finanzieren die Liberalen haben trotzdem
mitgemacht damals mit dem Ausweg
sondertöpfe nebenhaushalte und so weiter
und genau das ist jetzt vorbei der Kit
dieser Koalition ist weg und damit steht
besonders einer unter
[Musik]
Beschuss irgendwann stand ich ja mit
Christian lindmann mal so auf einem
presseabend die FDP hatte eingeladen und
Lindner sagte Bundes Finanzminister das
ist mein Traumjob ja wirklich wah
kürzlich habe ich ihn auf eine
Dienstreise ins Baltikum begleitet und
Lindner liebt das mit Startups reden mit
der
Ministerpräsidentin der mag die Rolle
aber in den letzten Wochen hat sich
dieser Job sicher für ihn in einen
Albtraum verwandelt denn er sah sich ja
bislang als Garant für seriöse
Haushaltspolitik und da waren die
richtig stolz drauf die Liberalen
2022 sagte er noch sowas die
Schuldenbremse gilt es ist vor allen
Dingen auch ein Gebot der ökonomischen
Klugheit dieses zur Schuldenbremse
zurückkehren das war für die Liberalen
ein richtiges Aushängeschild tja und
dann wird die Schuldenbremse für 2023
wieder ausgesetzt was muss da im
Hintergrund los sein Lindner steht mit
dem Rücken zur Wand ausgerechnet die
Schuldenbremse am Wochenende war
Landesparteitag der FDP in
Nordrhein-Westfallen da hatte ich nun
einige kritische Stimmen erwartet aber
die meisten Mitglieder der FDP sagen
2023 ja okay aber dann muss Schluss sein
2024 eben nicht mehr diese Notsituation
liegt aber für 2024 nicht mehr vor das
muss man so ganz klar sagen das sagt die
Bundesregierung aktuell noch nicht ich
sage das und deshalb sage ich auch ganz
klar 2024 müssen wir unbedingt wieder
zur Einhaltung der schuldenbrems
zurückkehren und das sehe ich auch als
absolut groute Linie für die jung
Liberalen der Finanzexperte der FDP
Frank Scheffler ist selbst im
Haushaltsausschuss und der hat dann auf
diesem Parteitag einen super schlauen
Schachzug gemacht er hat einen
Dringlichkeitsantrag eingebracht bracht
schaut mal und da heißt es eine erneute
Aussetzung der Schuldenbremse kommt für
uns nicht in Frage da die harten
Kriterien des Grundgesetzes derzeit
nicht gegeben sind und dieser Antrag
wurde dann fast einstimmig für
204 beschlossen das ist so ein richtiges
Druckmittel auf die Parteispitze sowieso
nicht nur die Ampel auch die FDP ist in
einer schwierigen
[Musik]
Lage tja und es gibt ja jetzt eine
Mitgliederbefragung dieser
fdpvorsitzender aus dem Kreisverband
Kassel hat 500 Stimmen zusammengesammelt
und nun muss die FDP all ihre Mitglieder
also 75 000 ungefähr fragen ob sie die
Ampel beenden wollen ja oder nein also
in meinen Augen war diese Ampel von
Anfang an eine Todgeburt wir verhelfen
rotgrüner Politik die eigentlich dem
Land schadet man kann fast sagen eine
deindustrialisierungspolitik und wir
verhelfen dem zur Mehrheit man muss dazu
sagen das Ergebnis dieser Mitglieder
befrag fragung ist überhaupt nicht
bindend aber natürlich macht das einen
Unterschied ob 20% oder 80% der
Mitglieder ein ampelende wollen ja oder
nein gerade schätze ich allerdings die
Lage eher so ein dass es wenige sind
denn allein für die 500 Stimmen hat er
fast einen Monat gebraucht aber
nichtsdestotrotz gerade die kertwende
bei der Schuldenbremse könnte Wasser auf
den Mühlen der Liberalen sein auch der
Bundestagsabgeordnete wolfgang kubiki
hat sich ja gegen Lindners Plan gestellt
denn er sieht es ähnlich kritisch der
Abgeordnete Mordhorst von den Liberalen
geht sogar noch weiter er schreibt ich
konnte mich auf dieses neue Bündnis
einlassen unter der Bedingung
Schuldenbremse und der Verzicht auf
Steuererhöhung das gilt als Bedingung
zumindest für meine Teilnahme ist das so
eine Drohung droht er das Ampel aus oder
das eigene aus es war ja lindner selbst
der 2012 plakatierte lieber neue Wahlen
als neue Schulden aber die Parteispitze
spielt das jetzt runter ich bin sehr
sicher dass die große Mehrheit gegen den
ampelaustritt ist wir machen hier nicht
den la fontain in schwierigen Zeiten
macht man sich nicht vom Acker und ich
glaube das wissen auch viele Liberale
und warum machen Sie nicht den lafontain
da geht man nicht von Schiff wenn das
Schiff schwankt sondern man sorgt dafür
dass es wieder ins Lot
[Musik]
kommt wie geht es jetzt weiter was meint
ihr schreibt es mir in die Kommentare
denn eins ist klar jetzt gerade steht es
spitz auf Knopf für die Ampel im
Bundesfinanzministerium kennen sie noch
immer nicht die genaue Summe die
eigentlich fehlt 60 bis 100 Milliarden
heißt es so grob Lindner hat da
vorsorglich schon einmal die
Subventionen für Strompreise gestrichen
fürs kommende Jahr das scheint auch der
Kanzler jetzt so zu sehen jedenfalls war
das die Message gerade in seiner
Regierungserklärung für FDP
Haushaltsexperte schfler ist die Lage
klar sparen also alle geplanten
Klimaprojekte müssten jetzt eingespart
werden und zwar gnadenlos und nicht nur
die auch müssen wir darüber nachdenken
ob wir am Bürgergeld sparen können ja
das war ein ein Fehler sag ich mal alle
ukrainischen Flüchtlinge automatisch ins
Bürgergeld zu lassen das muss korrigiert
werden aber auch die
Kindergrundsicherung so wie sie
angedacht ist ist aus meiner Sicht nicht
finanzierbar da gehen SPD und Grüne
natürlich auf die Barrikaden und machen
gleich klar wo nicht gespart werden kann
ich kann mir schlecht vorstellen dass
wir daranehen beispielsweise all die
Unterstützung für unsere Industrie die
wir gemacht haben damit sie durch diese
Krise kommen tatsächlich aufgeben und
ich kann mir auch schlecht vorstellen
dass wir aufhören beispielsweise mit 8
Milliarden jedes Jahr die Ukraine zu
unterstützen tja also wenn die Ampel so
verhandelt kommen wir aus diesem ganzen
Schlamassel ja nicht wieder raus FDP
Haushälter Fricke sieht das ein hat
jetzt auch vorgeschlagen eventuell über
Steuererhöhung nachzudenken allerdings
wurde das sofort von der Parteispitze
wieder eingefangen diskutiert wird also
der CO2 Preis die Rente mit 63 die
mütterrente und vielleicht vielleicht
auch eine Anpassung beim Bürgergeld im
Blick auch klimaschädliche Subventionen
wie das dieselprivileg ungefähr 8
Milliarden Euro Dienstwagenprivileg fast
6 Milliarden und mittelfristig auch
sowas wie das billige Kerosin in der
gesamte euu tja aber ich kann jetzt auch
schon mal aufzählen wo sie sich überall
nicht einigen können also Schuldenbremse
24 aufweichen Notlage 24 ausrufen
klimaschädliche Subvention sparen beim
Bürgergeld Chipfabriken bezuschussen
Steuer Erhöhung und und und und also es
gibt eine ganz lange Liste nicht
verhandelbarer Position und jetzt gerade
müsste die Ampel aber Handlungsfähigkeit
beweisen also alle müssen über ihren
Schatten springen was findet ihr was
kann weg was muss weg wo muss gespart
werden seht ihr überhaupt einen Ausweg
aus diesem Dilemma die
wirtschaftsweisein Veronika Grimm hat es
bei Land skizziert sie meint es bräuchte
eine neue Klimapolitik CO2 Bepreisung
beispielsweise und und da wird auch jede
der drei Regierungsparteien was abgeben
müssen es wird sicherlich Einsparungen
geben müssen und wahrscheinlich wird
jeder bei Dingen die ihm wichtig sind
auch nachgeben müssen irgendwie eine
ganz andere Richtung neu denken neue
Klimapolitik vielleicht auch neue
Schuldenbremse vielleicht weniger
sozialstat also wir können alle gespannt
sein das ist wirklich ein echter
Politkrimi der da gerade hinter den
Kulissen abläuft euch wünsche ich alles
Gute abonniert gerne unseren Kanal und
baut ih mit auf bis demnächst wieder bei
inside
politics